FROM KYIV, CNN'S MATTHEW CHANCE
HAS AN UPCLOSE LOOK AT HOW
UKRAINIANS ARE TRYING TO FIGHT
BACK AGAINST THE RUSSIAN
INVASION.
>> Reporter: THE AFTERMATH OF
FIERCE FIGHTING EAST OF THE
UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
THIS IS WHAT YOU GET WHEN YOU
INVADE UKRAINIAN LAND, THE
NARRATOR SAYS, AS RUSSIAN FORCES
ATTEMPT TO ENCIRCLE KYIV,
UKRAINIAN MILITARY SAY IT'S
DEFEATED AN ENTIRE REGIMENT OF
RUSSIAN TANKS AND LIQUIDATED ITS
COMMANDER.
DRONE VIDEO CAPTURED THE ARMORED
COLUMN IN THE CITY OF BROVERY
BEING ATTACKED AND DESTROYED.
THE LATEST BATTLEFIELD WIN IN
WHAT IS PROVING FOR NOW TO BE A
DETERMINED UKRAINIAN STAND.
BUT ON THE DIPLOMATIC FRONT,
STALEMATE.
DESPITE THE HIGHEST LEVEL TALKS
SINCE THIS RUSSIA/UKRAINE
CONFLICT BEGAN, FOREIGN
MINISTERS MEETING, UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS TELL CNN THE RUSSIAN
SIDE APPEARED UNWILLING OR
UNABLE TO MAKE A DEAL.
>> WE ALSO RAISED THE ISSUE OF A
CEASE-FIRE, 24-HOUR CEASE-FIRE
TO RESOLVE THE MOST PRESSING
HUMANITARIAN ISSUES.
WE DID NOT MAKE PROGRESS ON
THIS, SINCE IT SEEMS THAT THERE
ARE OTHER DECISION-MAKERS FOR
THIS MATTER IN RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: IT'S THESE
GUT-WRENCHING SCENES IN THE
UKRAINIAN CITY OF OF MARIUPOL
PROVOKING WIDE INTERNATIONAL
SCORN.
A MATERNITY HOSPITAL DEVASTATED
BY RUSSIAN FORCES.
ACCORDING TO UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS, KILLING AT LEAST
THREE PEOPLE INSIDE, INCLUDING A
CHILD.
HORRIFIC IMAGES ARE CIRCULATING
LIKE THIS ONE OF PREGNANT WOMEN
BLOODIED IN THE ATTACK.
STILL, THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER IS INSISTING THIS WAS A
LEGITIMATE STRIKE ON A FAR RIGHT
UKRAINIAN MILITIA, THE AZOFF
BATTALION, NOT A WAR CRIME.
>> AT THE MEETING OF THE U.N.
SECURITY COUNCIL, OUR DELEGATION
PRESENTED FACTS ABOUT THIS
MATERNITY HOSPITAL HAVING LONG
BEEN SEIZED BY THE AZOFF
BATTALION AND OTHER RADICALS AND
THEY HAVE DRIVEN ALL THE
PREGNANT WOMEN AND THE NURSES
OUT OF IT.
>> Reporter: BUT IN CITIES
ACROSS UKRAINE, TRAPPED
CIVILIANS ARE DESPERATELY
ESCAPING THE FIGHTING.
THESE, THE LATEST SCENES FROM
IRPIN NORTH OF KYIV, WHERE THE
CITY'S MAYOR SAYS NEARLY HALF
THE POPULATION HAS ALREADY FLED.
WITH NO PEACE IN SIGHT,
UKRAINE'S CAPITAL IS EMPTYING,
AS RUSSIAN FORCES ADVANCE.
JAKE, SHORTLY AFTER MEETING HIS
RUSSIAN COUNTERPART IN TURKEY,
THE UKRAINIAN FOREIGN MINISTER
TWEETED SOME ABSOLUTELY HORRIFIC
IMAGES OF A TODDLER WHO WAS VERY
BADLY INJURED BEING HURRIEDLY
EVACUATED FROM A SUBURB NORTH OF
THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
BASICALLY SAYING ALONG WITH THAT
TWEET THAT, LOOK, THIS IS WHAT
PUTIN HAS SENT HIS ARMY TO KILL
UKRAINIANS, INCLUDING CHILDREN.
HE POINTED OUT THAT OVER 70
CHILDREN HAVE SO FAR BEEN KILLED
IN THIS CONFLICT.
AND THE FOREIGN MINISTER OF
UKRAINE SAYING THAT HE WILL
PERSONALLY ENSURE THAT EACH WAR
CRIMINAL FACES JUSTICE, JAKE.
>> MATTHEW CHANCE REPORTING LIVE
FOR US FROM KYIV, THANK YOU.
STAY SAFE.
>>> HERE TO DISCUSS, DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR MARK WARNER OF VIRGINIA,
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
MR. CHAIRMAN, THANKS FOR JOINING
US.
ON THE QUESTION OF THE U.S.
HELPING THE POLISH GOVERNMENT TO
SEND THE SOVIET-MADE MIG FIGHTER
JETS TO UKRAINE, YOUR COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR JEANNE SHAHEEN, DEMOCRAT
OF NEW HAMPSHIRE, TOLD CNN,
QUOTE, IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY WE ARE
STANDING IN THE WAY.
EARLIER TODAY AND YESTERDAY TWO
DIFFERENT FORMER NATO SUPREME
ALLIED COMMANDERS TOLD US THAT
THEY THINK THE U.S. SHOULD BE
TRYING TO HELP THE POLISH
GOVERNMENT GET THESE MIGs TO
UKRAINE.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> WELL, JAKE, I BELIEVE WE ARE
SENDING A LOT OF AID, 17,000
ANTI-TANK TOOLS AND I JUST WAS
MEETING WITH SOME MORE BRITISH
COLLEAGUES.
THEY ANNOUNCED ANOTHER 3,600.
I THINK WE NEED TO GET MORE OF
THOSE TURKISH DRONES THAT HAVE
BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE.
THE QUESTION ON THE PLANES, I'D
LOVE TO FIND A WAY TO GET THE
PLANES TO THE UKRAINIANS.
WHAT I NEED TO GET THE ANSWER
TO, THOUGH, IS WILL THE BALANCE
OF NATO AGREE WITH THIS?
I KNOW THERE'S SOME ARGUMENT
COMING STRAIGHT FROM POLAND
VERSUS COMING FROM A NATO
AMERICAN AIR BASE IN GERMANY.
IS THAT A DISTINCTION WITH A
DIFFERENCE?
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET AN ANSWER
TO REALTIME IS, IS PART OF THE
RELUCTANCE THE FACT THAT OTHER
NATO MEMBERS ARE RELUCTANT TO
HAVE THAT MOVING FORWARD.
NATO STILL HAS -- I'M SORRY,
UKRAINE STILL HAS A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF ITS AIRPLANES THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO USE.
THE TRUTH IS A LOT OF THE
AIRSPACE, NOT ALL OF IT BY ANY
MEANS, BUT A LOT OF THE AIRSPACE
WHERE THE RUSSIANS HAVE CONTROL,
THEY ALSO HAVE CONTROL OF THE
AIRSPACE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
YOU'VE NOT SEEN THE EXISTING
UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE, FOR
EXAMPLE, BOMB THAT LONG COLUMN
THAT HAS BEEN SITTING FOR SO
LONG.
>> THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE TESTIFIED TODAY
THAT THERE'S A NEW ASSESSMENT
ABOUT UKRAINE THAT CONTRIBUTED
TO THE DECISION OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO NOT HELP THESE
POLISH MIGs GET TO UKRAINE.
DO YOU KNOW OF NEW INTELLIGENCE
SUGGESTING THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
MIGHT SEE THIS AS ESCALATORY AND
MIGHT BOMB POLAND OR SOME OTHER
NATO ALLY?
>> CLEARLY AS SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY THAT WAS EVEN MADE IN
PUBLIC TODAY, THAT TESTIMONY
THAT WAS MADE WAS BEFORE MY
COMMITTEE, THE OPEN THREAT
HEARING, AND WE WENT INTO A
CLOSED SESSION.
I OBVIOUSLY CAN'T SPEAK TO
ANYTHING ABOUT THE CLOSED
SESSION.
BUT THERE CLEARLY IS AN
ESCALATORY LADDER.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
THINK WAS POSED, IS IT THAT MUCH
MORE OF AN ESCALATION IF THE
PLANES FLY FROM A NATO BASE THAN
IF THEY WERE SOMEHOW TRANSPORTED
IN ANOTHER WAY FROM POLAND INTO
UKRAINE?
AND THE QUESTION I WANT ANSWERED
IS WHAT DO THE BALANCE OF NATO
NATIONS SAY?
THIS IS A GROUP THAT SO FAR, I
THINK, AGAIN BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS WORKED SO
HARD TO BUILD THIS COALITION, I
CAN ASSURE YOU A YEAR AGO NATO
WAS BROKEN IN THE AFTERMATH OF
TRUMP.
IT HAS BEEN BUILT BACK.
THE LAST FOUR MONTHS,
PARTICULARLY WITH OUR BRITISH
ALLIES.
WE'VE HAD TO CONVINCE THE
REALITY OF THE THREAT AND NOW
NATO HAS THAT.
WHAT I DON'T WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN
IS THAT UNIFIED FORCE AGAINST
PUTIN'S AGGRESSION SPLINTER IN
ANY WAY AND THAT'S THE QUESTION
I'M TRYING TO GET THE ANSWER TO.
>> THERE ARE ALL THESE PRO
RUSSIA SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS
TRYING TO CONVINCE THE PUBLIC
THAT THESE NEWS ACCOUNTS ABOUT
UKRAINIAN SUFFERING AND DYING
ARE NOT TRUE.
THEY'RE FALSELY CLAIMING THAT
THE VICTIMS WE'VE SEEN ON TV ARE
CRISIS ACTORS.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY OFFENSIVE AND
FALSE.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU
SEE THIS PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN BY
RUSSIA, THAT THESE ARE CRISIS
ACTORS AND NOT ACTUAL UKRAINIAN
VICTIMS?
>> WELL, JAKE, AS YOU MAY
RECALL, WHEN THE WAR FIRST
STARTED I WROTE ALL OF THE MAJOR
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO NOT
ALLOW RUSSIAN ENTITIES TO
MONETIZE THEMSELVES DURING THIS
TRAGEDY.
AND I'M A BIG CRITIC OF THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS FOR THE
MOST PART, BUT MOST OF THEM TOOK
OFF, RT TOOK OFF, SPUTNIK, MANY
OF THEM MADE CLEAR THAT THERE
WAS NOT AMERICAN ADVERTISING
BACKING THAT.
ON THE QUESTION, AND I'M TRYING
TO GET MORE INTEL ON THE FAKE
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
CONUNDRUM.
WE'VE GOT AMERICAN COMPANIES WHO
PROVIDE SOME OF THE INTERNET
BACKBONE FOR THE INTERNET IN
RUSSIA.
SOME OF THEM ARE EXITING.
AND ON THAT LEVEL I APPLAUD AND
MAYBE SOME OF THOSE RUSSIAN
SOCIAL MEDIA FAKE VIDEOS CANNOT
GET OUT WITHIN RUSSIA INTO THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT, OF
COURSE, IS THAT MANY OF THE
IMAGES OF OPPOSITION TO RUSSIA,
THERE WAS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE
RECENTLY WHERE THERE WAS A
GOVERNOR OUT IN SIBERIA AT SOME
FORM OF TOWN HALL, AND
RUSSIAN -- HIS CITIZENS WERE
BASICALLY SAYING WHY DID YOU
SEND OUR YOUNG MEN WHO WERE IN A
POLICE BRIGADE TO BELARUS?
YOU TOLD US THEY WERE GOING FOR
A TRAINING MISSION AND THEY'RE
BEING USED AS CANNON FODDER.
SO THAT OBVIOUSLY WAS WHERE THE
INTERNET WAS BEING USED AS A
POWERFUL STATEMENT FOR THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE TO HEAR SOME OF
THE PROTESTS.
SO GETTING THIS RIGHT, I DO
THINK THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
NEED TO DO MORE TO TAKE DOWN
THESE FALSE VIDEOS.
THAT IS SOMETHING
DISINFORMATION/MISINFORMAT